so i'm delighted to introduce our our
second invited speaker for 224n um
kelvin goo
so kelvin is a senior research scientist
at google with interests in
retrieval augmented language models and
using
knowledge in neural networks and is
perhaps
best known for his work on the realm
model which is
one of the things he'll doubtless talk
about today
um yeah
i guess i know there are a few
statistics students in the
class so maybe i'll also just mention
that actually kelvin's background is a
statistics phd but somewhere along the
line he got corrupted away from math and
statistics and ended up spending all of
his time on natural language processing
a very good move
i'll recommend it to anybody
so anyway i'm really happy to
have kelvin here today to tell us about
his recent work
nlp and as chris alluded to there'll be
a focus on memory augmented models
so um i'll try to kind of have a few
spots for people to for us to pause and
ask questions and um otherwise i'll i'll
take the slides away
great so i want to start by just giving
some motivation on some tasks that ai
cannot solve today
it cannot diagnose a medical patient
it can't fix your car
it can't perform novel scientific
research
it can't file corporate taxes
and it can't do many other things now
i'm not saying that artificial
intelligence is supposed to completely
do these things but at least it should
be able to assist people who are doing
those things
and what all of these tasks have in
common is that certainly intelligence is
required but domain knowledge in these
domains is just as important so it's not
it's not intelligence alone that enables
you to do these things
you have to have a long
experience in various things such as
what a car's components are or in the
case of this question here if you're to
ask a language model the part of the
intestine most commonly affected by
crohn's disease
is
my latest query to gpt2 says the rectum
but actually it's the ilium so
we can understand that if you're in the
medical field and you're making this
level of mistake then you probably need
to to go back to training
um
so we're interested in getting language
models and other language understanding
systems to make these fine-grained
distinctions well because we can't
really unlock the next set of
applications that nlp or ai could target
and of course this is something that
since the field began artificial
intelligence researchers have been very
interested in if you look at some of the
early applications of artificial
intelligence in the 60s and the 80s
there were expert systems that did
medical diagnosis
they would do computer chip design
and
of course we know that we didn't get to
completely fully solving those problems
and back then the big obstacle was that
you had to manually input all of the
knowledge required for that domain some
expert had to sit down and write all the
rules and if any one of those rules
contradicted another rule the system was
very brittle and unable to handle that
complexity
but in 2022 what's very exciting is that
we now have
language models as you've seen in
previous lectures that can automatically
acquire knowledge from the web and so
that gives us an exciting opportunity to
revisit this question of how to use
knowledge in artificial intelligence and
do more than you know classify whether
an image is a cat or a dog but move on
to much more complex tasks
so this talk will be
in three parts the first part is
we're going to look at how language
models currently represent knowledge
since they've obviously made huge gains
we need to understand what it is that's
powering that success
and then we're going to step back and
ask ourselves um
if that current way of representing
knowledge is what we're happy with and
what we'd actually like to see more of
and finally
kind of leading leading the
the discussion here we're going to
propose memory augmented models as a way
of addressing some of those challenges
so certainly not the only way to address
it but one way that we'll spend a lot of
this lecture looking at
okay so the first half of this talk is
about how language models currently
represent knowledge maybe the first
third
and
as i was actually looking at your
curriculum i realized there's another
lecture on knowledge editing coming up
this will be sort of an introduction to
that i won't go into it as much detail
as one of the later lectures but you can
think of this as an intro
so let's go back to this prompt that we
were looking at earlier and we know that
we have a model that is close to getting
a correct answer but in some ways not
that close
and so you'd like to ask yourself
this incorrect belief is clearly stored
somewhere in the model's parameters
but where exactly is it stored we know
that a gpt style model is a transformer
and a transformer has token embeddings
and a feed forward network and an
attention network
where exactly is the knowledge and how
can we identify it and fix it
so to to answer this question we're
going to look at some recent research on
knowledge editing
um knowledge editing is the following
task so
let's say the language model has some
original belief
like if you give it this fill in the
blank question eiffel tower is located
in the city of blanc you expect it to
predict paris
and the knowledge editing task says
we'd like to actually change the model's
belief about this so
let's say instead that we want the model
to believe that the eiffel tower is
located in rome instead
and we don't want it to just memorize
this exact statement but rather really
change its knowledge about the eiffel
tower so if i ask other questions about
the eiffel tower the answer should
change there too
here's like a particularly tricky one if
i say the tallest structure in rome is
the the new answer should actually be
eiffel tower
and we're going to look at this paper
which incidentally confusingly is also
called rome um by meng at all very
recent research which illustrates an
approach for doing this
so you can see here
on the top
they've made this particular edit that i
was talking about and when you generate
from the language model if you prompt it
about
places to eat those places are all in
rome and if you prompted about how to
get there from berlin the directions are
from berlin to rome so that's really
quite remarkable
and
the premise for this is that if we have
an approach that can actually make these
sorts of edits
it might constitute a little more of a
proof that we understand something about
the the internal structure of the
knowledge inside the model
so now let's let's get into how this
approach works and on the way learn
about how language models might
represent knowledge
um we're going to start actually with an
earlier paper
called
i think i paraphrased the title a little
bit but transformer feed forward layers
are key value memories
and what i mean by that is i'm referring
to the standard feed-forward layer
inside the transformer which i think you
guys have seen in an earlier lecture
it's essentially taking the input from
an earlier layer in the network and then
passing it through a matrix
multiplication a non-linearity and then
another matrix multiplication
wraps that with a bit of layer norm and
additional bias terms and
residual connections and that's
basically your feed forward network uh
as represented symbolically here so
right now i'm just giving this
simplified form of the feed forward
network because
this simplified form is enough for us to
understand the basic intuition
of how their this thing might storm
memory
um
and by key value memory i really just
mean it in the the typical python
dictionary sense so
in this key value memory the keys are
name and food and the values are kelvin
and pizza
okay so
i'm going to go into a kind of
operation by operation description of
what's happening happening in the
feedforward network let's let's look at
this first matrix multiplication first
and what we're going to do is we're
going to break this first weight matrix
into rows
so now i've got each of the row vectors
shown here
and as you know from from linear algebra
class
a matrix vector multiplication is just
the dot product of each row against the
input vector
and so you can get a set of scores for
each of those dot products
and you can think of those scores as
basically the similarity between x and
each of the rows
okay
now that we've got that set of
similarity scores we then pass it
through the non-linearity in the feed
forward network and the non-linearity in
transformers is often times something
like a value so it's a function
that takes the values and if it's
negative sets it to zero if it's
positive basically just keeps that value
so if you apply that transformation
you get another set of vectors and you
can see now that a bunch of the sorry
another set of values forming a vector
and you can see that a bunch of the
entries are now zero
okay so i still haven't explained why
this is a key value memory just bear
with me a little bit longer
we're going to go on to the second
matrix multiplication in the feed
forward layer
and this time we're going to break this
matrix up into column vectors
and we'll use the other interpretation
of matrix vector multiplication that you
get from linear algebra class
which is that
it can be interpreted as taking the
columns and forming a weighted sum of
those columns using the values in the
original vector
so i've just taken these values down
here and move them over the column
vectors so you can see what the weights
are on each of the column vectors
and because a lot of those entries are
zero we can just drop them so you can
see we've essentially selected certain
columns in the second weight matrix
and then we add them up
and that's the output
does anyone have any questions so far
about what happened there
okay cool so now i think after you've
seen that process we're ready to
ascribe a key value memory
interpretation to this
so let me just quickly show you the
whole process again
first we
multiply for the first matrix and get
the similarity scores between each of
the row vectors
pass it through a non-linearity
multiply by the second matrix
which in turn select certain columns of
the second matrix
add those columns together and get the
output
so when you look at this process you can
think of
this second matrix as storing values
that you are selecting
you can think of this matrix here that's
colored as the selector that's deciding
what memories are selected
and you can think of the first matrix as
storing keys which represent the things
that you want to select
so the reason we call this one on the
right keys is because if you think about
uh the input x
if input x is equal to one of the row
vectors in w1
then it will have high dot product with
that particular key and the score here
will be high for that entry and low for
all the other entries so essentially
each one of these keys
selects a particular value the first row
vector selects the first column vector
in the second matrix and so on and so
forth so that's the that's the key value
interpretation of a feed forward layer
and just to give just to kind of beat
this example to death
so you can
get get an example of how expressive
this model is let's suppose that the
keys are actually one hot vectors where
each entry or each row vector just has a
one in a different position
basically what i'll argue is that i can
select any combination of the
memory columns in this second matrix
over here by just setting different
values on the input so in this
particular example i've got a one here
and a one here
and that in turn selects these two keys
all the other dot products will be zero
and the selector will be only on for
those two entries which will select
these two values and if i had flipped
any of the other bits in this vector to
one or zero i could select any other
combination of memories so there's
really quite a lot of bit of flexibility
in this model
and it gives us a potential theoretical
explanation for how you could store and
select lots of different kinds of
information in a feed forward layer
um
okay so that's all theoretical so far
and it's it's just what a feed forward
layer could do we we actually want to
know
if feed forward layers do act this way
in a real transformer model
um and for that we're going to return to
the paper that i was mentioning earlier
called rome and we're going to look at
how a transformer actually behaves on
this particular prompt
all right so
as you know from previous classes on
transformers
basically
it processes the text from left to right
at least in a standard decoder model
and it builds the attention and feed
forward layers one at a time on top
going across like this
and on the next time step which i'm not
showing it has to predict what goes
there and currently in the basic model
it predicts paris
so
we want to know of each of these boxes
which one is actually storing the
knowledge
about the eiffel tower if that's a
reasonable question to ask at all
and we'll look at an approach that's
used in the rom paper that i mentioned
earlier called causal probing
and the technique the basic idea of
causal probing
is first you take some
uh random gaussian noise and you add it
to the word embeddings for eiffel and
tower
or if eiffel tower is broken up into
more sub words all of those subword
embeddings so that essentially confuses
the model
into not quite being able to recognize
what the entity is and they add enough
noise to the point where the model no
longer predicts paris
so once they've destroyed the model's
prediction
they then go about trying to restore the
original value
at each of these boxes one at a time
to try and recover the model's original
behavior so intuitively you would think
uh
if one of these boxes doesn't matter
like the model's not paying attention to
it even if you restore back to the
original value the prediction is not
going to go back
but if it is responsible when you
restore the value there's some hope that
the model returns to its original
prediction
and then they're just going to see which
layers are best at restoring the
original prediction
one thing i just want to say to clarify
is let's say
if i restore this value here in this
attention box
we have to recompute everything above it
because all the things above it need to
consume that new value so that's the
that's the restoration procedure
and what they found in this paper is
that feed forward layers above the last
token of eiffel tower are actually the
critical causal
layer that if you restore it you can get
the prediction to go back to its
original value and that's quite
interesting they tried restoring later
layers doesn't restore the prediction
they tried restoring earlier layers also
doesn't restore the prediction so
there's this very clear time band upon
which the causal
effect is let me let me show you guys a
quick plot
so this is just a plot from the original
paper
um
take a moment to interpret this so
on the y-axis here we have the different
time positions as the model is
processing different tokens so you can
see it's the big bang theory premieres
on
and then there's a date
and the big bang theory has stars on it
because that's the entity where the
noise is being added and then on the
x-axis you're seeing different layers of
the transformer as it's processing it
and the colored
intensity of the plot is the causal
effect of restoring
so what's what's very exciting is that
it all lands on theory
not not any tokens before that so this
is where the model apparently is
accessing the knowledge
and
it's sort of surprising because you
might imagine that the the knowledge is
kind of distributed everywhere maybe a
little bit of every time step
contributes and and that would be
unfortunate because it'd be harder to
modify the model's behavior if that were
the case but in fact it actually
concentrates
and they did this over a bunch of
different prompts
and looked at basically where they got
the most impact measuring the first
entity token middle last entity token
later words and it all concentrates very
well so that's an interesting
observation i i don't know what to do
with it yet research wise but i thought
you guys should know about it
okay so we're going to zoom in on this
feed forward layer
that they identified with this high
causal effect so they said it was in
this time step and they found that
effect to exist across many of the
layers and let's just let's just zoom in
on one of them
um
to get a better understanding of what's
going on here
so
as you guys already know from the
earlier slides we can
we can identify the selection vector
that comes out of the nonlinearity which
says which memories got selected in the
second weight
matrix and furthermore we know that this
output from this weight matrix is
responsible for predicting paris as we
saw from the previous plot so
intuitively that gives you this idea
that somehow we should be messing with
the weight matrix w2 to change its
behavior
and
you know a naive idea for how to change
its behavior
is well you know drawing on our
intuitions from word vectors maybe we
just pick one column from w2 the one
that the selector selects
and just subtract the word vector for
paris and add the word vector for rom
and it turns out that there is in fact a
paper which i've linked to here that
does that and it works to some extent so
they showed positive results with this
approach and that's that's really quite
surprising in on its own
um
the the particular paper that we've been
following the rome paper does something
slightly different but similar in spirit
so they apply a rank 1 update just to
the weight matrix w2 they don't touch w1
at all
kind of
consistent with our interpretation that
w2 contains the values of the memory and
w1 is just the keys
so what i mean by rank 1 update is w2 is
a matrix and i add to it
another matrix formed from outer
producting two vectors u and v transpose
and
these two vectors are parameters that
are optimized to maximize the
probability that the model outputs roam
while also minimizing the change in
behavior over all the other inputs
it's out of the scope of this class to
exactly describe what unv is or at least
not in this lecture so
i'll maybe just punt this off to eric's
lecture when he gets there
but i just wanted to show you guys this
to show the the level of fine grain
control people are starting to look into
in terms of editing knowledge in
language models
and this wouldn't be complete if i
didn't show you some more examples
so the successful example you guys
already saw on an earlier slide
but to also show you some not quite
successful examples just to show where
the field is right now they also gave an
example of trying to convince the model
that the game sonic drift 2 was not made
by sega but instead by microsoft
and here you can see what the model does
instead it really struggles
it claims that the game is now made by a
studio called play dead and this studio
was led by a former microsoft employee
so it's really kind of fighting against
what we're trying to make it change
and that's kind of where we are right
now
so that was the first section on how
language models
currently represent knowledge the the
main takeaways that i'd like you guys to
have is that the transformer feed
forward network can be viewed as a key
value memory and that's one of the
reasons why when you see people scaling
up transformers to larger sizes
oftentimes they decide to put that
scaling budget into making the feed
forward layer wider as opposed to making
the attention layer wider or adding more
layers because they're trying to
increase that memorization capacity
and the second conclusion is that
transformers tend to look up information
about the entity on the last token where
it's mentioned that's quite an
interesting thing too
prior to the rome paper there were other
papers that tried to just fine-tune the
entire network to get it to change its
behavior and when you fine tune all of
the parameters indeed you can get it to
change its behavior on rome but you also
mess up a bunch of other facts too so
being able to make a small edit to one
place actually does turn out to be
helpful
and lastly i just want to say this a
very new research area next year i could
be saying something completely different
um so just take that with a grain of
salt
okay so um we're going to go into the
the second half of the presentation and
we're going to talk
actually because we've still got time
are there any questions about the
previous slides
yeah yeah i'm actually curious you
mentioned about how to be surgical um
about knowledge alteration
empirically um did the researchers
discover
uh or with your own work i don't um
discover that if i alter you know eiffel
tower being wrong does it cause other
cascading effects of confusing rome with
paris or something of that sort
yeah yeah that's a great question so um
on the eval benchmarks that they have
now for this task they have um
i'm not sure if the exact word is like
neighbor prompts so
they have both
prompts that are paraphrases of the
original thing to test that the models
were best to paraphrase but they also
have prompts where they ask say about
sears tower or
other towers and make sure that those
towers didn't move to rome as well
uh and
yeah so that's very it's very imperfect
right now there's this difficult balance
between the two and that could be a sign
of many things it could be a sign that
the model doesn't have enough
memorization capacity so it's only way
of representing the eiffel tower is to
just think of it as like a tower
with maybe some nationality mixed in and
when you when you edit that tower you
just move all the other towers too
great question yeah
different like different types of
questions so like you asked about
michael collins where it is well what
about like um
kinds of properties about the company
and does the does the corresponding
team with respect to
um
yeah so i think if i understand your
question it's not just asking about that
one fact but other facts related to the
eiffel tower
yeah so they also have this kind of free
form generation prompt i think where
they just initialize it with eiffel
tower some short prompt and then they
measure
the different kinds of texts that come
out and i think if i remember correctly
they check like ngram overlap with real
text as well i didn't
so they have a couple more analyses in
the paper of how it behaves on other
topics too
yeah
one thing worth mentioning is um
uh i guess i've i worked with another
student here
on a um
uh paper on counter factual updates so
uh we we have this data set which we
should really get released out soon
that
pairs one fact update with another
implication of that fact update that is
non-obvious so for example if if walt
disney had one of his academy awards
script then the next question would be
how many academy awards did walt disney
win
and
that's like one of the areas that i
think some researchers are thinking
about for future work
so the current method basically
only allows control through the prompt
so
uh whatever the prompt implies about the
entity you get to change what the answer
to that prompt is
and it's it's basically at the moment up
to the model to decide what implications
are affected by changing that prompt
which is another you could say weakness
of the approach it's not entirely
interpretable everything is done through
optimization
yeah great question
um okay we'll go on for now and then
oh oh yeah go away
okay yeah the question is about whether
the low rank update has anything to do
with adversarial machine learning um i'd
say maybe there is a is a slight
connection in that if you look more
deeply in the paper what they're doing
is they're
they're optimizing
uh
the output of the weight matrix to to
change the label and that optimization
procedure is very similar to what they
do in adversarial machine learning
the low rankedness of it is not
necessarily connected to the adversarial
learning the low rank part is just to
minimize the amount of change to the
weight matrix
i can maybe just quickly do this on the
board here so
if you have this weight matrix w2 plus u
v
transpose
the reason this is a small this is
considered a small update to the matrix
is because if you think about anything
multiplying w2 after it's received this
update let's say you're multiplying it
by x right so this whole thing is
multiplied by x
so let's just move this x into the
expression you get w 2 times x and then
u v transpose times x and this part
right here is just what w two originally
would have done and this part right here
uh this vector v is being dot producted
with x
and in in high dimensional spaces
basically
most things dot products are zero
and so this quantity here is likely to
be zero unless x is very close to v and
then this whole update here basically
disappears
so in that sense you could think of a
low rank update as a very small change
to weight matrix
okay cool we'll move on to the next
section
um
all right
so now we've seen what language models
currently do to represent knowledge or
at least a theory about that and we'd
like to ask ourselves well is that
really it do we just need to make feed
forward layers bigger and bigger to
achieve you know uh the singularity or
whatever it is that artificial
intelligence researchers are focused on
these days
okay
so
what is missing from transformers right
now we we can automatically acquire
knowledge from the web
but a lot of that information can be
noisy or incorrect so the web certainly
has its share of misinformation or
rumors and opinions
and when it when it absorbs that
misinformation or other things we can't
trace the model's knowledge back to an
attributable source so we can trace it
back to a particular layer in a feed
forward network but that still doesn't
tell us where in the training data it
learned that
now that would all be okay if we could
then surgically edit the model to fix up
all of those errors
but as you've seen it doesn't work very
reliably yet
and another fact that i didn't mention
is if you apply a bunch of these edits
in sequence to the model eventually the
the parameters get kind of
so damaged from the edits that it
doesn't maintain its original
performance anymore
and we can continue to try storing
knowledge inside feed forward layers
but the current memorization capacity is
still too small
even though we're building these very
large and expensive models
so we can rephrase some of these issues
as a wish list for what we would want in
a knowledge based
language model we'd want fast and
modular knowledge editing so be able to
robustly edit the model multiple times
without breaking it
we'd like attribution and
interpretability so tracing a model's
knowledge back to something in its
training set
and we'd like efficient scaling so we'd
like to be able to increase the model's
memory size by 10x without paying 10x
more compute
and to give a motivating example let's
let's just say you wanted to use
something like gpd3 to do question
answering over your company or
school wiki
at the moment as we know a single
training run at least when it was
originally done cost over 12 million
dollars and we just can't afford to do
that for every organization that wants
to train a system off of their data
and furthermore information is
constantly being updated over time for
example like the covid requirements
for for being on campus so all of this
sort of motivates this wish list that
i'm i'm giving here
so with that we'll turn to
the next main half of the lecture which
is on memory augmented models
so let me first just give a basic
overview of what a memory augmented
model is um to start with let's just
consider a standard neural network model
which takes some sort of input like this
one here
passes it through some dense computation
and then produces some output and the
difference that we're going to make to
this model
is
we're going to attach a memory retriever
to it so the input is going to be fed
into this memory retriever which then
accesses some external knowledge source
that can be easily scaled easily edited
easily understood by humans like
wikipedia
and from that we'll try to identify some
piece of information that is relevant
for the task at hand and feed it back
into the neural network and then produce
the prediction
so that's the basic approach that we're
thinking about
and the the memory that the memory
retriever selects can be any number of
things it could be a document on the web
could be a record in a database it could
be a training example
entity embedding i uh i'm just going to
focus on text for now but
most of what we'll talk about in this
lecture can apply to
other
other kinds of objects and you should
just keep that in mind that it's really
not just about text
so this potentially meets our wish list
of things we'd like to do
you can easily edit the knowledge in
something like wikipedia you can easily
attribute back to it there's a source
there's an author for everything that's
put in there and there's efficient
scaling because i can always add more
articles to wikipedia and i don't have
to change the size of a neural network
that's accessing it
and some motivating applications for why
you would care about this
if you're building an open domain
dialogue or question answering system
you want to have robust access to
knowledge
by retrieving documents on the web
if you're generating code i'm pretty
sure all of us are guilty of at least
some point
going on stack overflow and copying a
snippet so even we do retrieval we are
in a form a form of memory augmented
model
if you're doing image generation if
somebody tells you i want a picture of
the eiffel tower on the white house lawn
you might consult some reference
pictures of those objects
and if you're doing fact checking you
might want to retrieve documents that
support or refute a claim all these
things are very knowledge intensive
tasks and could benefit from an approach
like this
um
yeah yeah that's a great question so the
question is whether you have to retrieve
one memory and that's not the case i'm
going to use that as like the simplified
example that we'll work with but you
could retrieve multiple memories um the
complexity of retrieving multiple
memories increases and we'll maybe get
to that in a little bit good question
yeah
okay
uh all right
so um the rest of this talk is going to
be structured around the main design
questions around how to design a memory
augmented model
so first you have to choose what your
memories are i'm actually not going to
focus on that much because based on your
application you can usually guess what
you would want your memories to be
and then we're going to think very hard
about how to retrieve the memories
that's essentially the heart maybe the
hardest part of the problem
approaches we'll look at are you could
use an off the off-the-shelf search
engine like google or stack overflow
or you could train your own memory
retriever which we'll spend some time on
and lastly we'll end by looking at how
to use retrieved memories
so
we'll cover a few different approaches
such as text fusion label smearing
and perhaps most interestingly i'll talk
about a few common failure modes for
when models try to use memory
one of them is something that we'll call
under utilization where the model
actually ignores the retrieved memories
and another one is over reliance where
the model somehow kind of becomes too
dependent on memory and i'll talk about
that when we get there
okay
so let's go into the um the section on
retrieving memories so i'll kind of
organize them into two broad groups so
one is the set of approaches that use an
external tool
and the other is the set where you train
your own
and we'll start with
an approach that uses an external tool
just because i think some of those
approaches have been really popping up
this year and are quite exciting
the first approach we'll look at is from
this paper called lambda which stands
for language models for dialogue
applications
so on the right we've got a dialogue
between a human user and the model this
is a i think a real dialogue from their
paper
and the user is just asking about a
particular artist and the model is
giving a very spirited reply complete
with personal opinions and even
follow-up information
so
lambda is an open domain dialog chatbot
that's designed to cover a very large
range of topics so you need some kind of
memory component that's able to handle
anything the user might throw at the
model
and the basic version of the model
is just a transformer decoder so it's
the same kind of transformer that we
were studying in the previous slides
the input to that transformer is
essentially the previous turns of the
conversation represented as text and the
output is just a new utterance that it
needs to generate also as text so it's
just a text-to-text kind of approach
um what's new though
okay not quite there yeah so
one last thing about this model though
is as they were developing it they
noticed that it often generated
factually incorrect claims so
just to highlight that this last claim
that the model makes is factually
incorrect in this case this particular
artist that was supposedly inspired by
the earlier artists star stopped working
before the first one began working so
this this just can't be true
um and their approach to solving this
problem will be to teach their base
model to learn to use a search engine to
validate or fix claims that it's made so
i'll show you how that approach works on
the next slide
the basic idea is you've got a user
interacting with lambda which is this
big box here and what they've decided to
do is have multiple agents inside the
big box that can kind of interact with
each other and kind of work things out
before they give a reply back to the
user
so here's how it might go
the user says to the base model when was
the iphone tower eiffel tower built and
the base model replies it was
constructed in 1887 but unlike the the
basic approach it doesn't send that
response immediately back to the user it
actually sends it to
this agent called research
and then research then takes that
information and decides okay you know
this claim looks a little bit
um
you know sketchy i'm going to send a
query to the search engine um i'm
anthropomorphizing a bunch here but it
just helps with the explanation
and then the search engine then replies
back with the web search results for
that query and in it we have actually
the correct answer which is 1889.
so research then takes that information
and
produces a new response that has the
corrected information and sends that
back to the user so that's the overall
flow of the approach and you can see
that the search engine is able to
intervene to fix a model's responses
any questions about that
okay yeah the question was whether this
happens uh whether this particular flow
happens for all questions to the model
and actually as we'll see in a later
slide
the model gets to decide who it talks to
next so base has to decide to talk to
research as opposed to talking to the
user
um so there's there's a learning process
where
each agent gets to decide whether to go
right back to the user or to talk to
another one of the other agents
go ahead
okay yeah the question is how to limit
the amount of information coming back
from the search engine um
i think in this particular approach the
search engine returns the first snippet
and then if research is still not happy
it asks the same question again and then
they've designed it so the search engine
returns the next snippet so it just sort
of yields control back to the
to the research
yeah yeah
go back and correct the base model so
that it doesn't make
in the future
yeah okay so the question is whether
research sends any feedback back to the
base model that it's made a mistake and
that's a great idea i don't think they
do that in the paper
they just
i mean research overrides base so the
user gets what research said but base
never learns i think from what research
says so that's a really yeah that's a
really great point
what are you the back there
okay so the question is
why do we need the base model um yeah
that's a great point too so um lambda is
kind of the the researchers who
developed it cared not just about
answering factual questions but making
it interesting and fun and engaging so
the base model has a lot of that
engaging behavior
and they wanted to preserve that while
still preserving factuality so the other
two agents are kind of there to police
the base model um that's maybe one
explanation
all right great great questions um so
now that we've seen the overall control
flow of the model we can look at how the
model is trained and it's actually quite
simple so their modeling approach is to
just treat everything as dialogue
so
let's look at a particular turn of the
model's operation
so there's been a couple turns of
conversation so far
which i've listed here
and you can see it's just saying who
talked and who and who they talk to
and the output at this particular time
step is just another person to talk and
who it should talk to
so all of this is just text
it's text going in it's text going out
so you guys have seen transformer models
and basically this fits right into the
contract of a standard transformer model
the only kind of special detail is that
when you generate the text you have to
start your sentence with who you're
addressing and that that provides the
control of which agent responds next
uh i already mentioned this
and
the perhaps the most important question
is okay we've got this text-to-text data
where do we how do we train this model
and the approach in lambda is actually
quite simple too
they basically just get human
demonstrations so human crowd workers
play the role of user and research in
this dialogue there are people who are
looking at the base models utterances
and saying oh i don't like that i think
a search query should be sent here
and when the search results come back
they're reading the results and then
deciding how lambda should respond
instead so it's a really elegant and
simple approach but it does require you
to have trained crowd workers and put in
a good amount of budget to to get the
behavior you want but still quite
impressive that they're able to do this
this is a real example i think from the
paper
cool any questions there
all right so um although the approach is
simple it actually achieves quite a bit
so the model learns to reformulate the
previous turns of the conversation as a
query that can go into google search so
it's kind of shoehorning the problem
into something that google search or you
know some kind of web search can
understand
and then it's learning also from human
demonstrations how to incorporate the
knowledge
from the search results back into the
utterance that it's putting out
and
just because this work also came out
around the same time and also very
exciting i'd also point you to web gpt
which is another model that learns to
use web search
in their case they provide human
demonstrators with an actual ui and have
human demonstrators use that but they
ultimately i think convert the history
of actions that the user takes again
into a piece of text that the model then
simply consumes and uses to predict the
next action
the additional thing here is that they
use reinforcement learning to then
fine-tune their system further on top of
what they learn from human
demonstrations and that's something
worth checking out as well
so the main takeaways for this little
section here is that many external
retrieval tools accept text as input and
return text as output
so if you want to have an external
memory and interface with one of these
things all the task really boils down to
is learning to generate text queries to
that external tool
and then learning to understand the text
output of the tool
and both of these tasks can be handled
by standard off-the-shelf tools that all
of you are already familiar with from
previous lectures
as long as you have demonstrations for
how to do that
or if you're able to do rl training
which we won't cover here so that's the
overview of how to use external search
tools you can imagine that if you had a
database instead of a web search you
could
provide demonstrations of how to write
sql queries to that database
or any other sort of tool that you could
imagine
all right so at this point you might say
all right we can query web search and
web search is very powerful so why would
we use anything else
and to that i have a couple responses so
first of all web search is just far from
perfect and the reason it's as good as
it is today is because of research and
we're here to do research so if you're
just going to rely on web search being
good that sort of defeats the point
if you don't if you don't believe me try
some of these queries so if you search
for a famous lawyer who got into car
accident
you'll find that all the results are
about lawyers you can call if you get
into a car accident
if you search for use nlp to parse
research papers you will find a bunch of
research papers on parsing and after
doing a few of these the the illusion of
web search working really well kind of
fades away a little bit
and also if you if you speak a language
other than english you might find that
search performance in different
languages is really not quite the same
so there's still a lot to do to improve
retrieval in web search and
i sort of consider
web search to be just sort of a
component inside the the larger bigger
set of things that memory augmented
models could could potentially do
and second of all just the plain api of
web search isn't designed to handle
everything you might want to do
so you could imagine a doctor given a
medical image might want to retrieve
similar images from a medical textbook
that's not quite something that web
search is cut out to do right now
or if you're a programmer who's been
given a programming challenge you might
want to retrieve relevant algorithms
also something web search doesn't do
if you're in fashion if you're given
three pieces of clothing can you
retrieve another piece of clothing that
completes your outfit or if you're a
novelist and you're given a story
retrieve other stories that have the
same plot
or if you're a journalist if you're
given a claim retrieve news articles
that refute or contradict it these are
all retrieval tasks that would be quite
useful but existing search tools just
don't handle and so
these are all reasons why i think the
retrieval problem is still interesting
to look at
and a third and final point is that web
search only accesses public data so if
you have any task that doesn't
condition on public data you're still
going to need a retriever of your own
cool
so with that we'll turn to
the next part of the talk which is how
to train your own neural retriever um
which is something that
sort of i find very interesting
so we'll start by giving an anatomy of a
neural retriever
kind of similar to what we showed for
feedforward networks and transformers
we're going to go with this key value
type of interpretation so you have a set
of keys paired with a set of values
and given some input you're going to
compute some sort of similarity score
between the input and each of the keys
and
once you've computed that score you
basically want to return the value
associated with the highest scoring key
or you could return the values for the
top k highest scoring keys or any other
metric
so to just kind of ground this example
the input could be something like eiffel
tower location the keys could be titles
of documents and the values could be the
corresponding text associated with the
document
and the the basic takeaway here is just
that a retriever is really just a
function that takes some input and a key
and produces a score once you have that
you basically have a retriever you score
all the memories and then you take the
ones that have the highest score
for the remaining slides i'll actually
go with a slightly simplified setup
because in many tasks there's really no
distinction between the keys and the
value sometimes they're just the same
thing so for example with wikipedia
documents you just take the whole text
as the key and the value
and so i'll go with this simplified
schematic where you're just computing
scores against
what i'll call memories and the highest
scoring memory is what's returned from
the memory retriever
and we'll go with this formulation that
the retriever is just a function that
takes the input in the memory and
produces a score
okay so i've said it's just a function
but how what what sort of functions do
people actually use in practice to
compute this score and the answer here
is not too surprising
you guys have seen bert and other sorts
of transformers in previous classes it's
a very flexible model class i'm trying
not to introduce kind of unnecessary
complexity so we'll just go with a burp
model that takes
the input in the memory and you put a
some sort of regression layer on top of
the output layer of bird so maybe the
cls token embedding of burt you put a
regression layer on top and it produces
some float valued score
and this whole thing is differentiable
so the regression layer is
differentiable burt is differentiable
this gives you basically a neural
network that produces a score
and the advantages are you get this very
powerful model that's comparing the
input against the memory and it's
differentiable so all of that is good
the disadvantage of this approach is
that
if you have
millions of memories then every time a
new input comes in in order to retrieve
a memory you have to run this
computation against all one million of
the memories
so that's just way too expensive to do
if you if you're thinking about
something like all of wikipedia or all
of the web
so next we'll turn to um a different
architecture that is more commonly used
for retrieval
on the next slide
so it's very similar
the burp picture comes up again this
time what we're doing is we're taking
the input and feeding only the input
into the transformer to produce a single
vector that we'll call the input vector
and then we'll have a separate
transformer encode each memory
separately to produce a memory vector
for each memory
and then the relevant score between the
input and the memory is just the dot
product
of these two vectors
it could be the dot product it could be
cosine similarity just any function that
you can efficiently compute between two
vectors
so
so why are we proposing this instead
this has a couple advantages over the
previous architecture
the first is that you can run
this side of the model the right side
on all of the memories
in advance so before any inputs even
come in you can just pre-compute the
memory vector for each thing so if it's
wikipedia you can produce a vector for
every document in wikipedia
and when a new memory comes in you don't
have to redo that work
so that saves a lot of compute the only
thing that you need to do when a new
input comes in is you need to compute
this input vector and then do dot
products against all of the memories
so dot products are cheap and can happen
much more quickly than running an entire
burp model over again and that's the
fundamental savings that you get from
using a model like this
something that we won't cover
in as much detail here is that for the
dot product there are also
fast
nearest neighbors algorithms that let
you efficiently find the
memory vectors that have the highest dot
product with the input vector without
actually
computing over all of the memory vectors
so it's a sub-linear search algorithm
that allows you to find it and the basic
intuition there at least there are a
couple of them is that you can take your
set of memory vectors and build some
sort of tree structure over them kind of
organizing them spatially once you've
built that tree structure when the new
input vector comes in
you can essentially kind of traverse
down that tree to find the things that
are most similar without computing dot
products with everything else
there are other algorithms too that use
hashing and other techniques but that'll
be out of the scope for for today's
class
and the other good property here is that
all this is still differentiable so you
can still train this thing with gradient
descent like anything else
the main disadvantage of this approach
is also kind of due to its advantage
which is that all of the expressiveness
of this model has to go through that one
dot product so anything you want to
remember about the input or anything you
want to remember about the memory all
has to get squeezed into that one memory
vector and that one input vector and
that's a bottleneck that kind of
researchers have been dealing with in
recent research
what you'll find is that there are a lot
of approaches that try to strike some
kind of balance between this approach
and the approach on the previous slide
so a common thing to do is to use this
approach to retrieve a top set of
candidates
and then run a more complex model like
the one on the previous slide to rescore
and re-rank
the candidates proposed by the first
model
you'll also find techniques that try to
take the memory and produce five vectors
and then use all five of those to
somehow compute a score there are many
variations but we won't go into detail
here
any questions
okay right there
okay there's a question about whether
you can
kind of augment the the search data
structure
that uh that helps you do the fast
search
um
i think there is some research in the
area where
the
the
vectors that you produce to index the
tree is perhaps not the same as the set
that you ultimately return
they can be optimized for different
things so oftentimes these kind of tree
based approaches require your vectors to
be spread out in some non-pathological
way
and i think that's a very interesting
area for research so
producing vectors that are easily
indexable kind of taking into account
the indexing process as a way to
improve overall performance is quite
important too
because oftentimes when you use these
fast similarity methods they they make
some sort of approximation to the real
top case search and those approximations
can often hurt you pretty bad yeah great
question
oh
did you have a question okay all right
cool
um great so now we've looked at a few
different architectures for actually
performing retrieval
now let's look at how you would actually
train one of these retrievers
so
fundamentally all you need to train a
retriever is you need an example of an
input
you need a positive example of what you
would like to retrieve
and then you need some negative examples
of what you would not like to retrieve
so for example where the super bowl is
this year sears tower location etc
and
the the training objective for this is
quite straightforward so i'm going to
define a few variables here
s star will be the score that the
retriever assigns to the correct input
and s sub i is going to be the score
that the retriever assigns to each of
the negative inputs
and then we're going to apply the
well-known softmax function over all of
these scores
so what we're doing here is we're taking
each of these scores
exponentiating the scores so that
there's some positive value and then
dividing each of those exponentiated
scores by the sum of all of those scores
so that the whole thing sums up to one
and we're going to call that the
probability of retrieving the positive
document so intuitively if the positive
document has a high score
then after exponentiation it'll be even
bigger the other scores will be smaller
and most of the mass in this probability
distribution will be on the positive
document
if it's not then this probability will
be small and what we will do
as a standard in machine learning is
we're going to maximize the probability
of that quantity in particular the log
probability
and this is all doable because p of
positive depends on the softmax
expression here which is differentiable
and each of the scores inside the
softmax depends on the retriever which i
just told you on the previous slide is
also differentiable so the whole thing
is differentiable and you're just
basically trying to push the positive
score
essentially above all the negative
scores
okay so it's a very simple recipe and
we'll look at a concrete example of that
based on this paper called dense passage
retrieval dpr
one of the early papers to explore this
sort of supervised retrieval approach
the task they're looking at is basically
given a question like the one here
retrieve a passage from wikipedia
containing the answer
and once you've
retrieved the passage they then have a
reader module that reads the passage and
produces an answer
and the training data for the retriever
is going to fit into the format that i
just described
so
they they work with this data set called
natural questions which comes with human
annotated queries
answers to the queries and also a
passage that contains the answer
so um here we go the input to our memory
is the query
the positive memory that we'll want to
push up is the passage that the human
provided and the negative memories are
actually something kind of interesting
in this paper
so it's going to be
one it's going to be the positive
passages for other queries so as long as
all your queries aren't asking the same
question the positive passage for
another query is going to be negative
for the current query that you're
looking at
and this next
bullet is also interesting
they take a passage that's retrieved by
an off-the-shelf tool for search
this is called bm25 it's a classic
information retrieval approach that uses
token-based overlap to retrieve things
it doesn't have any deep learning or
anything in it but it's um quite
effective so they retrieve a passage and
they retrieve one that does not contain
the answer in it so the assumption here
is that you've got a passage that looks
very promising but in fact doesn't
contain the answer and you can think of
that as this is what we call hard
negative
um great so we've got all the components
for training retriever they go ahead and
do that
let's look at how well it actually works
so to understand how well it works we're
going to compare it against a
another approach so
we're going to look at
this this is from i should have had a
citation for this too
a paper by robert sedal on closed book
question answering
they basically take a sequence to
sequence neural network model
called t5 and just feed in the question
and ask it to break the answer so this
model does not have access to passages
in effect it doesn't have any external
memory
and you can see that as they scaled up
the size of the model they were quite
nicely getting better and better
performance on the task
and the question we want to ask is with
dpr which has this external memory this
access to wikipedia can that do better
than an approach that doesn't have
external memory
and
the
the answer of course in this in this
class is yes so
um it does indeed improve quite
significantly and it's not a surprise
because we have access to this
additional uh information which is uh
wikipedia
so you might look at that previous chart
and say well maybe we just need to make
t5 bigger
because after all the scaling was
looking quite good right so i took that
plot and re-plotted it
with with the parameter scale on the
x-axis and the performance on the y-axis
and we know from recent research that
these scaling laws are tend to be
logarithmic so as you increase your
model size the improvement is a
logarithmic function and i just plotted
that curve out for you to see where it's
headed and if you plot dpr on this curve
it's just kind of sitting way above this
scaling plot for a much smaller model
size it's doing much better
and i also replotted this
out further to see if this line
eventually caught up with the 44 number
up there and it does at around 8
trillion parameters
so that's about like a thousand times
bigger than where we are now
so all this is to say that like scaling
does help but there might be easier and
cheaper ways to get there
so
one criticism you could make of the
previous
uh approach was that dpr actually had
access to something that t5 didn't have
which is it had human annotated gold
passages saying what you needed to
retrieve to answer the question and that
data is actually hard to collect
so we're going to ask the question
what if the examples that you had access
to were just query answer pairs can you
still train
a good retriever
without gold passages
and this this sort of task arises in
many other tasks as well
you could imagine if you're going from
natural language to code you might
encounter cases where nobody has
provided you annotations of what code
snippets to retrieve
medical diagnosis similar thing
so we're going to go now to end-to-end
learning of a retriever and let me get
into some detail on what that is so
we're coming back to this diagram of a
memory retriever
and in a memory augmented model once the
memory is retrieved it then goes into a
reader component which takes the
original input in the memory and
produces an answer
so if you have no supervision for the
memory
you might have this intuition instead
which is that if you did retrieve a good
memory that should result in a good
answer from the reader
on the other hand if you retrieved a bad
memory that will probably cause the
reader to get confused and produce a bad
result so
you might be able to use that
observation as a training signal to
train your retriever
let me just give a concrete example with
this who is the bad guy in lord of the
rings
if the memory retrieves something like
the main antagonist is sauron then
you'll produce sauron likely and that's
great on the other hand if the retriever
got this other passage saying
lord of the
rings received a bad review from imdb
then your reader might be more inclined
to produce imdb which would be which
would not match the gold answer in your
training data set so this gives you some
knowledge that the second memory is bad
and the first one is good
and so what i'm going to propose here is
this idea of trial and error
in the first stage you perform
exploration where you let your imperfect
retriever select some memory and you try
feeding that memory to the reader and
then you learn from success or failure
so if the memory helps the reader
generate the right answer you want to
increase the score of that memory
and if the memory does not help the
retriever you want to decrease the score
of that memory
and over time this process would help
the helpful memories get higher scores
than the less helpful ones
so
the formal approach for this is going to
be taken from a paper by one of my
colleagues
called open retrieval qa orca
and the exploration component we're
going to formalize as follows so as i
mentioned earlier a retriever is just a
scoring function between an input and a
memory
and if you take a soft max over all of
the scores for all of the memories
then you get this distribution over
memories given the input so again i've
just raised all of the scores to you
know e to the power of the scores and
then normalize
uh and once we have this distribution
we'll me we'll randomly sample memory
from that distribution so as you can
imagine if the if the scores are
meaningful then we're more likely to
sample a memory that's good and less
likely to sample a memory that's bad but
because it's random we kind of
eventually will sample everything unless
there are things with zero probability
and then
the learning from success and failure
part
so
once we pick a memory we need to see if
it actually helps
and
we're going to measure that by looking
at the reader's probability of
generating the right answer given that
particular memory
so that's this big quantity right here
the reader looks at the input and the
memory and we want to see its
probability of generating the gold
answer
and if this value is high then we want
to increase the score of that memory and
if it's low we want to probably decrease
the score of the memory
so i've shown you a couple express like
sort of
expressions now and we want to put those
expressions together into a training
objective that we can actually optimize
so
we'll start with this question if we
randomly sample memory from the
retriever and then we generate an answer
what is the overall probability that we
get the answer right
so first let's look at this expression
right here this is a summation over all
possible memories that the retriever
could retrieve and the sum is over the
probability of retrieving it so right
now this is this just equals one because
it's a distribution and we're summing
over all of its values
but then we'll add one more term to this
which is the probability that the reader
gets the answer right given the memory
in that term in the summation
so this first part is the retriever and
it's proposing different memories
and this second part is the reader and
it's succeeding or failing based on the
memories
so you can think of each term in this
summation as a trial of a different
memory
and you can think of that second term
kind of like a reward
if it's high
it's good and if it's low it's bad
so what they propose in the orca paper
is to perform gradient descent on this
entire expression right here
they basically want to push the value of
this entire expression up and they're
optimizing both the retriever and the
reader so let's look at the
retriever first so the retriever has a
fixed budget that has to sum up to one
over all of the memories if it wants
this value to be high
it doesn't have any incentive to put
probability on bad memories because
those bad memories are just going to
produce a low score on this term right
here so as you optimize this function
the retriever will basically try to put
all of its mass on the good memories and
meanwhile if you're optimizing the
reader with respect to this function
it's trying its best to produce the gold
answer given whatever memory it has
so it's also incentivized to try its
best to extract the answer out of
whatever it's given and when you kind of
jointly optimize both over time you get
something that puts its mass on good
memories
so that kind of corresponds with the
intuition that i was giving you earlier
that
you can kind of perform end-to-end
learning
to get a retriever
all right so that's the high level
approach to orca um what i didn't
explain is that usually if your memories
are like all of wikipedia this summation
is very large and if you're going to do
gradient descent on the summation it's
going to take a very long time so in
practice they approximate the summation
with the highest probability memories
maybe the top 100 or the top 10.
and i won't go into details in this
class about exactly how that works but
i'll start i'll stop there
because we're kind of approaching the
end i'm going to take questions just a
little bit later
sorry about that
so okay let's see how well orca works
just come out and put that number there
so a bit of context around this it's not
as good as dpr because it has less
supervision than dpr there's no human
annotation of what passage to retrieve
but what's worth noticing is that at
least compared to t5 at the same size so
you can compare 0.66 billion parameters
against 0.77 it's actually already
better than t5
and compared to a t5 that's about 15
times larger it's almost at the same
performance too so it's a it's a pretty
decent result for
an approach that has no access to
retrieval supervision
so
one thing you might note though is that
the better result requires gold passages
and orca and t5 these approaches don't
require gold passages they only need
query answer pairs and one advantage of
that is that
query answer paired data is actually
pretty easy to get so we could
potentially get a lot more of it than if
we were asking for passage passages as
well
and the the final part of this
retrieval section is about a way to get
basically an arbitrary number of query
answer pairs to kind of improve these
weakly supervised approaches that don't
have passages so it comes from a very
simple observation which is let's take
your typical query answer pair it looks
like this right so you've got your query
on the left and answer on the right
you can easily reformulate that as a
fill in the blank question like this
and this fill in the blank question
forces the model to think just as hard
as the original question is just in a
different format
but what's nice about this fill in the
blank question is that it's very easy to
create a bunch of them for free
basically you can just take any sentence
on the web and as long as it's
mentioning something factual or
semantically meaningful
you can just blank out one of the
entities
and in fact that is exactly what you've
probably seen in previous lectures
pre-trained language models like bert do
and bert uses that training objective to
learn a very great deal
and that can be used in this setting for
retrieval as well
so the basic idea for
realm which is
something that i worked on with
collaborators is to apply the same
end-to-end training as orca but
pre-train the model on a bunch of these
fill in the blank questions that we just
automatically generated
just in extremely large quantities
and then we fine tune that on the real
questions
query answer pairs that we already have
so if you do this approach and you plot
it against all the others what's quite
nice is that it basically almost closes
the gap completely with an approach that
uses supervised data
just by pre-training on
fill-in-the-blank questions and the nice
thing is it doesn't need access to gold
passages so it's on the same footing as
things like t5 now
and at the same footing it outperforms
t5 despite being much smaller than even
the largest model so that gives us
this interesting promise of using kind
of language model fill-in-the-blank
techniques to build good memory
retrievers
and the nice thing is that this fill in
the blank approach can be used to
to tackle many sorts of tasks
you could blank out a patch in an image
and train a retriever to find other
images that might help fill it in you
could blank out a segment of code and
train a retriever to find
other pieces of code that might help
fill that in or chapter in a textbook
the kind of list of things you can do
with fill in the blank actually goes on
and on
and each task that you define in this
way produces a specialized memory
retriever for whatever it is that you're
filling the blank in for
and there's no need to collect training
data so this sort of scales to any any
set of tasks that may not be important
enough or central enough to warrant a
big data collection budget
all right so the main takeaways for this
section are that a retriever is just a
function that takes an input and a
memory and produces a score
if you have supervised data for your
retriever that's great
provide positive and negative memories
for each input and just train the
retriever to score the positive ones
higher
if you don't have supervision you can
use end-to-end learning
which employs a trial and error approach
if if a memory helps the model
score the memory higher otherwise score
it lower
and with end-to-end learning you often
get this special benefit that you can
easily create tons of data to pre-train
your retriever
all right we're now into the very very
final part of the of the
talk which is how to actually use the
memories after you get them
chris i have 15 minutes right
yeah 14. 14.
okay all right then we should have
plenty of time for questions actually
so all right here we go
um we're going to come back to this
diagram of a memory augmented model
and now we're going to focus on this
reader component which i didn't say much
about before i said that the reader
takes the memory and the input and then
produces the answer so what does that
reader component actually look like
a very common architecture is just the
sequence encoder to decoder model
in in practical terms you take the
original question and you just
concatenate it to the memory that you
retrieved and then you feed that into
your encoder and you train it using
standard sequence to sequence learning
to produce the output so all we're doing
is just concatenating the memory with
the input
and
we can refer to that as text fusion
anytime you have a memory that is text
or can be converted into text in some
form just just concatenate it that's all
you need
at least that's what that's what state
of the art techniques are doing right
now
okay and just to give some variety there
here's another way to incorporate
memories
let's consider a slightly different
memory augmented model where instead of
just retrieving a document the memory is
actually key value pairs where the key
is the question
like a question that's been seen before
and the value is the answer to that
previously seen question
so in this case you can do something
even simpler than what was on the
previous slide you can take your input
and compare it to the keys and find the
key that most resembles the input so in
this case we found a paraphrase of the
original question
and if you have this
then
all you really need to do is just copy
the answer from the value out as as your
label
and that's what people refer to as label
smearing or otherwise nearest neighbors
methods we call it smearing because
you're essentially smearing the label
from this example that you retrieved
onto the new example
and it's a very simple technique which
one you use depends on your application
so
the techniques for using memories are
quite simple but the problems that arise
when you use them are actually quite
interesting
the first one i want to talk about i
kind of mentioned this previewed this
earlier are these two problems of under
utilization and over reliance so let's
get into the under utilization issue
this is from a very recent paper by long
pre-at all
so let me dive into it so
um
okay i switched the example here because
i just got tired of the lord of the
rings one
the question is who do you meet at the
gates of heaven and the retrieved memory
is on point it says you see saint peter
at the gates of heaven the reader reads
it produces saint peter everything is
great so what long pre had all observed
is okay if if the reader is really doing
such a great job of reading the memories
then if i edit the memory to say
something else the reader should pick up
on that and produce the different answer
so what they do is they change saint
peter to the united nations
uh guards the gates of heaven
and
they check if the reader actually
produces the united nations
but surprisingly the reader still says
that saint peter
guards the gates of heaven and this is
really quite interesting and pretty
funny so what's actually going on here
let's let's first look at how bad this
problem is
so here's a plot from the paper
the first row here is
the model's behavior on the training set
for natural questions the same data set
we were looking at earlier
and the red part of this plot indicates
the number of times where the model
sticks with its old answer even after
changing the memory it just stubbornly
refuses to change the blue part is the
good part where it actually switches
over to predicting the united nations on
various examples and this other orange
part is very concerning too so
when you change the memory to united
nations sometimes the model just gets
confused and predicts something totally
different not st peter not united
nations just something completely
different
so from this we can see something is
really kind of broken about some of
these memory augmented models and the
same kind of behavior happens on the dev
set as
well uh and just to underscore how bad
this is this is a these
results are from the set of examples
that the original model was actually
getting all correct so you just kind of
cut the performance of your model by
more than half
when you edit the memories and that
indicates the model's not robust to
change
as we said earlier being able to edit
your memories is something you would
really want from a memory augmented
model
so
let's let's have an analysis of why this
happens
basically when you put this memory into
the sequence encoder the reader that
reads the the memory um
this encoder and this decoder they
actually have their own memory as well
as we saw in the earlier slides
transformers have their own memory so
we'll refer to that as the parametric
memory of the encoder decoder as opposed
to the external memory that we want it
to rely on
and
at training time they essentially learn
to store the answer in their parametric
memory and not rely on the external
memory
so to give
this
issue a better cartoon form the input is
coming in and the model has its own
parametric memory and the retrieve
memory
and the parametric memory is saying st
peter and the retrieve memory at
training time is also saying saint peter
and the loss function is saying you must
predict saint peter so the model says
okay i've got two sources of information
i can choose either one there's nothing
forcing the model to use the retrieved
memory
and that's part of the problem that's
causing this another problem which isn't
on this slide is that sometimes the
retriever is just not very good so it
might retrieve something that's just not
related to the question and in that case
the model is forced to fall back on its
parametric memory and again learn to
distrust the retrieved memory
so we want a way um
to kind of force the model to pick the
retrieved memory instead
ideally we would want cases where the
parametric memory is wrong and the
retrieved memory is correct that would
force the model to say hey i can't trust
my parametric memory
so what long pre-add-all do
is first they take the retrieve memory
and they change what the retrieved
memory is saying so this creates a
disagreement now between the parametric
memory and the retrieve memory
but the gold label is still saying st
peter so we've just made the matters
worse now because now the retrieve
memory is even less trustworthy
the final thing they do which is really
the interesting bit is they just decide
to change the gold label as well to
agree with their retrieved memory so
they've changed reality and said no
actually the united nations guards the
gates of heaven and what's in your
parametric memory is wrong
and that's basically the approach so
they create a bunch of data like this
where the gold answer has been changed
to match the corruption they made in the
retrieve memory and it guides the model
away from using the parametric memory
i thought that was a pretty cool trick
and
they don't give this name in the paper
but you can think of it as data
augmentation using these counterfactual
memories and it can really be applied to
a lot of different approaches as long as
your memory is editable in a certain way
and you can edit the gold label as well
you can create this
artificial correlation between the
memory and the output and an artificial
anti-correlation between the output and
whatever your model originally trained
on
it's cool so now we want to see if it
works
and in the paper they report this metric
which is basically the percentage of
time the model predicts the old value
instead of the new one divided by the
old plus the new
they ignore the set where the model gets
confused and produces something totally
different i wish they had reported that
too but i couldn't immediately find it
in their paper
but at least on this metric things look
great so on the training set in the dev
set the percentage of the time that the
model uses the old memory of the old
answer goes dramatically down with this
data augmentation so it really keeps the
model on its toes and makes it use its
memory now i take this result with a
little grain of salt because
their test set is created the same way
that they produce this data augmentation
so
this is kind of the ideal setup where
they're almost testing on the exact same
distribution that they're training on
but still a very interesting approach
so let's see how long how long do we
have left okay in the last few minutes
i'm going to cover the over reliance
problem and there's just one slide on
this so sometimes the memories that your
model retrieves are too easy uh here's
what i mean by that so if we go back to
this eiffel tower query where was the
eiffel tower well what year was the
eiffel tower built
we know it's 1889 and a good typical
memory that you might retrieve is
something like this it says work on the
eiffel tower was completed in 1889.
there's not too much
word overlap with the original query
which is good because it teaches the
reader to
recognize the fact that completed in
this context is the same as built so the
reader learns paraphrase
on the other hand you might get a memory
that's too easy which literally just
says exactly the same tokens as the
original input
and you could also consider
yeah so this example would not teach the
model uh how to paraphrase
and at the other extreme you could also
consider an extremely challenging memory
like paris's tallest tower finished the
same year van gogh painted the starry
night
so yes that also says the same fact but
the answer doesn't even directly appear
it's just
too hard for the model
so
if all of your examples are like this
too easy memory then you end up with a
reader that is kind of spoiled it never
it never learns to paraphrase and at
test time if your memories that are
retrieved are not as good the reader is
not going to be able to use them so a
simple fix to this problem i don't have
a paper that i can cite exactly for this
but at training time you can simply
filter out some of the memories that
have lexical overlap that's too high
at the same time you also want to make
sure that you don't filter out so many
of the easy things that you're just left
with the super hard cases like the one
on the bottom because if you only have
the super hard cases your model will get
confused and as we saw in the previous
slides it might just fall back on its
parametric memory so this is sort of
just an area for open research of how to
give the reader a flexible set of things
to train from
great yeah so i've covered pretty much
everything in that section as well and
the main takeaways i'd like for you guys
to have is that getting your model to
use memories is not hard
there are some simple approaches but
getting your model to use memory
correctly is actually an interesting
open question and there's this issue of
under-utilization and over-reliance that
are open areas of research
and that's it i hope that you guys saw
some interesting things about memory
augmented models and are encouraged to
look into that area if there any
questions please feel free to email me
or message me
happy to talk about it more and thanks
for sitting through a 90-minute lecture
[Applause]
you